Community Pride on 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Finley Automotive Group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
Southwest Medical hospice the sponsors
of this segment has been offering
medical and emotional services for the
past 30 years here to tell us more about
their palliative care services medical
director Dr Lisa Rosenberg welcome to
the show thank you so much for having us
today it's great to see you so nice to
see you what services do you guys offer
Las Vegas so we actually have Southwest
Medical Hospice Services and then we
have Optum care palliative care which
also brings Great Value to our to our
members our patients yeah and what what
is palliative care so palliative care is
palliative care yes yes oh sorry I did
it correctly you said it quickly we
we're just happy to hear the words
actually
um so it is really an extra layer of
support for patients who have chronic
life limiting or function limiting
illness so it really helps patients and
families to deal with the uh the medical
aspect but also the psychosocial aspect
the stress of facing serious illness we
help educate families and patients about
what they can expect and also how to
advocate for themselves with the system
is there is a particular case or person
that you're working with did you give us
an example of how things work so so I
think a lady that I'd like to talk about
is named Roberta she is a 56 year old
lady who unfortunately has a
life-limiting illness she also recently
lost a close family member and she is
raising her three very young
grandchildren so this is a lady who
needs and deserves a lot of support we
were able to we so we provide the
services I just described we have nurses
and providers that go to the home social
worker dietitian and we have a chaplain
in our on the palliative care side so
we're really proud of that over the
holidays we had a bunch of volunteers
get together and we made baskets and we
delivered her a basket of clothing and
gift cards and toys so that she could
provide for her grandchildren what she
might not have been able to to provide
just on her own she's actually taking
care of that one person you're taking
care of Roberta but you're also taking
care of the other people in her life yes
absolutely is her case kind of unique
situation or is that how you handle
every person that comes we bring we
bring individualized care so it really
is what people need
we do have people in the community that
are raising their kids kids for various
reasons but we try to go in and find out
what the person needs when I meet a
palliative care patient I do ask them do
you want spiritual support do you want
to meet our chaplain his name's Doug
he's awesome
um we're really proud of of the work
that we do we our social workers often
help to address what we call social
determinants of health so Financial
challenges either to getting the medical
care that's needed or making sure that
food and rent are paid for while we're
getting the medical care I love it you
guys are angels which you are thank you
so much Dr Lisa for joining the show it
was a pleasure having you on here Las
Vegas now we will be right back